good morning hank it's thursday pizza
misses hurtling toward its conclusion
which means that all the amazing
pizzamas stuff including this truly
extraordinary t-shirt is available only
for a couple more days at pizzamist.com
front load the promo it's question
thursday of the day that i answer real
questions from real nerdfighters let's
get right to it favorite pizza miss
merch i mean it's all incredible but
this pizza john scene where all these
people drew pizza john from memory is
it's magic also i absolutely love this
blanket i mean sometimes i marvel not
just at the existence of pizzamas but at
its longevity like how is a ten-year-old
joke getting funnier would you rather
have one john sized pizza or a hundred
pizza-sized johns i feel like the 100
pizza sized john's has both more
potential risk and more potential reward
like on the one hand it might be
stressful to have 100 tiny neurotic
people inside my house all the time but
on the other hand maybe they could do
some of my work for me actually the more
i think about it the 100 pizza size
johns are gonna be way more trouble than
they're worth i'm gonna pick the pizza i
should always just pick the pizza do
people ever tell you that your head
looks bigger in person not that i can
recall most people when they meet me for
the first time don't comment on my
appearance at all which by the way is
probably the way to go in such
encounters what does your late night
youtube look like i watch a lot of this
guy sanding cow hooves i don't know why
i'm not particularly interested in the
field of sanding cow hooves but i also
can't stop watching how's your brother
dave uh you know dave he's just kind of
doing dave's stuff i used to feel bad
for dave because he didn't have a
twitter and a youtube and all that but
now i think maybe he just achieved
enlightenment is there more to love than
just chemicals probably not but you know
really good chemicals why did you stop
making videos about unerotic giraffe sex
okay so first off there is no other kind
of giraffe sex but secondly this gets at
something that's pretty personal and
deep which is that i look at myself from
12 years ago and i think oh goodness did
he want to be popular and then
i got enough of that to want it less
best fact you learned this week i signed
up to have hank text me a terrible pizza
joke every day of pizzimas and in the
one from yesterday i learned that the
musician pink worked at pizza hut which
is like not a particularly interesting
or important fact but it's also the only
fact i can remember learning in the past
week why do i know the color of the
rented lamborghini that justin bieber
was arrested in a decade ago but i don't
know the name of like my children's
classmates parents like i look at them
and i'm like i know that we have been
introduced countless times and your name
is
jim i always think it's jim but it's
never jim what was the question pink
worked at pizza hut favorite art
assignment in sarah's book i use a lot
of them i use them to find quiet i use
them to decide what to write about and
also kind of what to think about but the
one i use the most is this one never
seen never will in which you are asked
to articulate something that you know
exists but that you have never seen and
probably will never see because for me
it's a way into thinking about the fact
that i don't know almost everything do
you have any recommendations for
breathing exercises i do life on the
internet often moves so fast that we
forget that we're breathing like check
out how long this breath takes
that's an eternity in youtube time
here's what i find personally helpful i
try to take a few conscious breaths and
then i remind myself of the strange and
lovely fact that my lungs were made for
this air it's not like a metaphor or
live laugh lovey to say that my breath
is deeply interwoven with all life on
this planet and with the basic chemical
makeup of earth and i try to remind
myself of that all right that got a
little serious steer it back to pizza
miss hank i'm gonna miss pizzamas so
much when it's gone i will see you
tomorrow